foreign
has to do with tweaking
um our budget my wife found out today
that she may
um lose her job and this wouldn't happen
until November and that's an
aeronautical engineer I'm trying to
stress test start budget
um so my question why would she lose her
job in November
well the company she works for is I
think in lieu of doing straight layoffs
or making everyone in Human Resources
reapply for their jobs
yeah it's odd she said there's an 80
chance that she won't lose her job but
again I just want to stress test this
and make sure that we uh you know if we
do lose her income that we you know can
still keep our four walls going what she
make
she makes 125 and straight salary I make
185 in straight salary I do get a bonus
in stock options which would bring up my
pay to around 330 but I don't like to
count on bonuses and stocks so I just
just use our straight salaries as uh for
budgeting
so you
ought to live on your salary gun dude
really
yeah so my question has to do with um do
I pull back on
you know 529s for our children and then
oh right now we've absolutely funded you
can't live on 180 Grand
oh we can okay I'm just asking where I
should tweak my budget you shouldn't we
I mean you you can do anything you're
doing right now on 180 Grand
can't you
yeah if we you know don't
put extra money into savings accounts
yeah we can there you go
so if in the 20 chance she loses her job
uh you don't put extra money in savings
until she gets a new job
you're killing me here yeah yeah yeah
what do you say you're keeping keep
stacking money keep doing everything
you're doing and you're already you're
already stacking money yeah like crazy
you're making so dead gun much money is
ridiculous awesome way to go
congratulations and how quickly does she
not doesn't she get re-employed really
fast
oh yeah easily yeah yeah nothing to
worry about here so I mean what do you
what are you really gonna lose I mean
you're gonna lose uh one month of income
or something like that and if they do
all that they're probably going to give
her a severance
right yeah I I don't know I I think that
this is their way of not having to give
people silences by making everyone
reapply for a job I I honestly
with what I'm hearing there unless
there's something I'm not that I don't
know uh if I were in her shoes I'm
looking for a job hundrew these people
it's wacky that's a nut if you think
they're trying to figure out a way to
not give people Severance and they're
too too uh uh wussified to just do a
straight layoff because they're broke
instead they go through this foe thing
this pretend thing like reapply look if
if you didn't want me just fire me
you know that's so true why do you have
to reapply so you can figure out you oh
well we wouldn't hire you again well
then fire them I mean my God yeah if I
look around here and somebody I wouldn't
hire them again that means their job's
in trouble right so I mean this is bad
leadership I'm probably out of there for
those reasons anyway but long before
they get a rent let me here I got your
reapply right here's my here's my
resignation that's exactly right don't
wait for the shoe to drop kale and
here's a he's a professional Warrior and
what I mean by that by nature of what he
does well he should be he's God he keeps
airplanes in the air that's right and so
he's not flying an airplane I want him
to be a professional Warrior so it's
okay Mikhail those are really good
questions but uh you didn't need us as
much as you just need to look at well
what would be what would need to be true
for us to be in really bad shape and
it's just not gonna happen you don't
have a scenario where you end up in bad
shape you guys are so you're stress
tested okay you're done you're just not
gonna stack quite as much money in your
absolute worst case scenario oh well
you're okay you're stress tested you're
good however you got some uh
advice that you didn't pay for yeah and
that is go ahead tell her go and quit
yeah get another job yeah and and just
say you know I'm going to help you with
this reapplication thing yeah or show up
with an office unless there's unless
they're just wonderful right people and
this is the only stupid butt thing
they've done but I just about guarantee
you that a leadership team that doesn't
have the the um uh backbone to lay
people off that in a situation where
they're broke and they can't and they
don't they don't have they they don't
have the capacity emotionally to do to
run their business that they're probably
making many other leadership mistakes
that are based on virtue signaling or
some other bull crap and so yeah I'm out
of there man I'm I'm betting you I'm out
of there but maybe maybe I'm wrong maybe
it's a wonderful place other than this
one stupid thing but usually this is one
of about 10 stupid things that that
place is doing and I'm an Executor I'm
with Dave that doesn't just that's not a
one-off that's a really wacky philosophy
on how to lead people it freaks people
out you specialize in that you know you
communicate well to our company you know
and it's like why would you create all
this unnecessary angst for some people
well you got chocolate you got the whole
place on the chopper that's right it's
weird instead of just going uh five of
you are gone right you know uh the rest
of you're okay you know I mean yeah I
yeah it's just good communication and
people appreciate it they they
appreciate bad news yeah more than they
appreciate ambivalence that's correct we
want to know where we stand and uh
that's your leadership lesson for the
day boys and girls tell people even if
it's bad news because here's the thing
if they don't hear bad news from you
they hear it in their head and they make
up crap and it's worse than the actual
reality the bad news boy isn't that the
truth and so that's what's going on with
this whole company when we're all going
to reapply